aux etats unis le vario delta lui
conseillant déjà une contamination sur
deux lors d'une brève allocution à la
nation hier soir le président américain
a annoncé un réajustement de sa
politique de vaccination en mettant
l'accent notamment sur les classes les
plus défavorisées
voyez les précisions de notre
correspondant à washington qu'un abonné
lors d'une courte prise de parole joe
biden a d'abord fait part de son
optimisme nous n'avons jamais été aussi
près de déclarer notre indépendance face
au virus a déclaré le locataire de la
maison blanche en revenant sur de bons
indicateurs sanitaires une baisse de 90%
des cas et des décès depuis le mois de
janvier le mois où joe biden est entré à
la maison blanche
mais il ya donc une inquiétude et cette
inquiétude c'est le variant delta c'est
pour cette raison qu'il y avait ce mardi
une réunion en tour de joe biden et de
ses conseillers sanitaire puisque ce
variant delta est responsable
aujourd'hui de la moitié des
contaminations sur l'ensemble du
territoire américain
il est responsable aussi de pic
épidémique localisé à certains endroits
dans certains états notamment auprès de
la population - vacciner ou non vacciner
écoutez les détails de joe boyd a connu
l'équité l'égalité
cela reste au coeur de notre
responsabilité de veiller à ce que les
communautés les plus durement touchés
par le virus
dispose des informations et de l'accès
nécessaire pour se faire vacciner
ainsi au fur et à mesure que nous
abandonnerons ces sites de vaccination
de masse où des milliers de personnes
qui vacciner chaque jour nous mettrons
davantage l'accent sur la possibilité de
se faire vacciner dans sa communauté
près de chez soi de manière pratique et
dans un lieu qui vous est déjà familier
le variant delta est déjà responsable de
la moitié des cas dans de nombreuses
rues
du pays où les plus facilement
transmissible potentiellement plus
dangereux et ils devraient faire l'objet
d'un réexamen est écouté laissez moi le
dire autrement
il me semble que cela devrait inciter
tout le monde à y réfléchir deux fois
c'est semer alors pour faire face à
cette résurgence à ces résurgences
localiser joe biden a annoncé une série
de mesures d'abord il a encore une fois
encouragées tous les américains à se
vacciner vaccinez vous s'il vous plaît
at il répété à plusieurs reprises mais
il ya donc des mesures avec des équipes
qui vont être déployés sur l'ensemble du
territoire pour aller au plus près de
ses pics épidémiques pour tenter de les
freiner et parmi ces mesures on pourra
noter la possibilité pour les médecins
traitants de vacciner mais également le
fait d'encourager les 12 18 ans à se
faire vacciner avant de retourner à
l'école la vaccination sera désormais
possible sur le lieu de travail ou
encore la mise en place de cliniques
mobiles lors d'événements qui rassemble
des foules là encore pour tenter de
vacciner le plus grand nombre ce qui
concerne les mesures de restriction elle
ne devrait pas être ré imposé en tout
cas à l'échelle nationale c'est ce qu'a
déclaré la porte parole de la maison
blanche
un peu plus tôt ce mardi pas de retour
du port du masque obligatoire en
intérieur ou en extérieur d'un point de
vue national mais liberté est donnée à
des entités plus locale à des employeurs
de faire comme bon leur semble et on
sait que dans un certain nombre
d'endroits dans un certain nombre
d'entreprises
le retour du port du masque est
désormais obligatoire pour donc un
certain nombre de comtés ont je pense
par exemple au comté de los angeles
quant à la vaccination obligatoire là
encore ce n'est pas d'actualité pour ce
qui concerne le gouvernement américain
mais on sait que certaines entreprises
certaines entités comme des écoles ou
des universités compte véritablement
mettre en place cette vaccination
obligatoire prochainement